[Music]
guys three days ago was February 24th
oh no what I don't know I thought I was
supposed to be it's bad that's bad right
well we're getting older Thank You a
24th was Kobe and Gianna's Oh
celebration of Memorial yeah Memorial at
the Staples Center see Michael Jordan it
was - aw yeah he cried it in like so sad
because he's like I look like penis yeah
because as soon as I cut to him crying
like the very first shot I was like oh
man this is little sad like and he goes
the meme yeah he's like I know I'm gonna
deal with being a meme for another four
years I know it's so good watching it
live but when we tuned in was
immediately after he said that so we met
we missed that oh you missed the center
yeah so good we just saw everyone
laughing were like crap did you talk
about the meme yeah yeah I love Michael
Jordan he's awesome man if he dies I
will cry for three days Michael Jordan
is one of my [ __ ] heroes from when I
was a little kid now man the sadder hero
like speech during that [ __ ] was on his
wife uh killed bro I was out saw that I
was up there's like the dealership
waiting on Mike might like some tire
[ __ ] to get done and like but they had
it on and I was like my laptop's trying
to get work and I look that looks like
in the joke like because she was like
I'll never see my daughter get to walk
down the aisle
oh yeah it's like there's a cannot watch
her eulogy and like not cry it's
impossible so sad man yeah but what
we're talking about here today they did
it so soon - he's such a strong woman to
even be able to like I know go out in
front of thousands of people like that's
what blew me away
really that time even worn I'm like I
would be a wreck yeah I would be a
little bit on stage like he's not gone
yet [ __ ] what are we doing this
for what do you mean
oh yeah oh you think you can fake this
if like Tupac I would've got mad at all
y'all for telling me somebody died where
she would it's a coping mechanism
sometimes it really is but anyway the
reason we're talking about it now is
because as you guys may have known
Beyonce performed the opening of the
memorial lady's favorite song okay
reason while we're talking about Beyonce
is because photographers were forbidden
from taking photos of Beyonce during her
performance one and a lot of people were
like what the [ __ ] this is the
Associated Press and getty images which
are respectable like what like
photographers individuals were allowed
to take pictures no so i'm talking about
the press oh like the press people
weren't allowed they were forbidden had
weed that picker because these are
screenshots of the actual live
performance word thank you do not from
like getty images or associated problems
it doesn't know exactly was a good oh
yeah a little blurry did you really see
this is a spill of a video yeah that
mildly like freedom of the press kind of
thing is that why they're passed or i
don't know that much about it but
they're just saying that they're pissed
because this just makes her look fat
it's not about Beyonce it's a bolshie it
was just specifically she was like her
people were like only me but if it's not
about Beyonce then not taking pictures
of Beyonce is kind of not about Beyonce
huh
yeah well she was trying to do
they had a staple center staffer to be
on the lookout to make sure not a single
camera was focused on the stage when she
was performing I get what she's going
for that makes sense to me yeah because
when you see those and you see 50 like a
carpet event mm-hmm box [ __ ] Oh
especially when Kobe's wife is there and
yeah yeah it's like a Beyonce concert I
totally get it yeah that seems to be the
approach of as to why they did it but
then this is what some people are saying
so one person at the event said it is so
offensive to Kobe's family and the fans
Beyonce is so controlling over image she
usually only allows approved selected
images of her to be released so no
photographers at the Kobe Memorial were
allowed to take her picture really at a
memorial not even the family of Michael
Jackson did that dude what if Beyonce's
like oh my god guys I got sweaty pits
can we not we do what we tell him
right we'll be Tel Aviv what were they
allowed to take pictures of everything
else except for her well the only other
thing that they mentioned in this
article that they were not allowed to
take photos of is Kobe Bryant's children
so they're kind of turning it as if
she's a diva yeah that's the angle first
of all we know she's a diva right she is
Beyonce when you say Beyonce you think
Dee Dee's like kind of like you like why
wouldn't she be a diva you know I'm
saying like it's Beyonce let her let her
do what she wants or a lot of people it
just makes it seem like tacky and it
makes her look bad where she's making it
about her but I get that she was trying
not to make it about her yeah cuz the
press is making it about them that they
can't give me pictures now that's what
they do a lot so it's like they get paid
you pass yeah and then another thing is
that ever since that Super Bowl
performance do you guys remember where
she was like looking like yeah easily
picture of her yeah yeah so ever since
then she has been on everyone's ass to
make sure to not capture any still they
even tackled some guy that was taking a
photo and she just so happened to be in
the background and they tackled this
dude and took the phone away and was
like making sure they didn't have any
photos of Beyonce
she's like that controlling and so
people were just pissed where it's like
[ __ ] is saying about you no one cares
about you everyone cares about if
Michael Jordan people were this good
there wouldn't be no [ __ ] me Michael
Jordan it's such a great meme Michael
Jordan starting to cry the guy [ __ ]
delete that [ __ ] from his phone yeah hey
look you get what you pay for man
Michael Jordan give a [ __ ] yeah Michael
joins the mean forever you owned it yep
no but then Beyonce maybe let it slip
the Superbowl and then she's like this
is why I have people hello she's like I
got millions of dollars to spend less on
frivolous [ __ ] let me pay a bunch of
people to make sure they don't get
pictures out I got caught hulking out at
the Superbowl
BuzzFeed they ended up creating this
article of like what was it I forgot
what the title of it but they ended up
posting a screen grab of an email from
Beyonce's people that said thanks for
taking my call as discussed there are
some unflattering photos on your current
feed that we are we are respectfully
asking you to change I am certain you
will be able to find some better photos
and the new link it and then they say
the worst our number five number six I'm
at an 11 over 12 number 19 number 22
beyonce is like micromanaging every step
of the way I don't like that photo I
don't like this sound like [ __ ] I'm just
gonna scroll through that order Hulk and
worst one there's a worse than there's a
worse one that's not even not even bad
yeah that's pretty bad mentioned in the
right dose there's a lot of passion
how's that I like those yeah these are
great but what's wrong with those photos
Beyonce doesn't like them okay guys if
Beyonce doesn't like them it doesn't go
up yeah it's the moon validator feeling
it's the mouth nose yeah you know I'm
saying she's walking out there yeah no
one knows maybe it's not even beyond sir
it was just her PR team doesn't like
probably that's possible right if NGO
because girls very can be very selective
about photography oh yeah if you could
have people who did this [ __ ] would you
do that [ __ ] yes right would you make
hey picture seven fourteen eight
taury if i was at her level I wouldn't
touch it at all it just makes you look
even worse the fact that you're after it
but what if those pigs got out I see a
little bit differently because at least
for Beyonce's she's selling her image
yes she's making her money so she's not
looking for like if she was like known
to be an author then yeah I would I
would be on JK Rowling's wouldn't it be
great if that picture of Fergie out
there of her pissing herself wasn't out
there
she really beeps off yeah I think so I
mean it's pretty nothing once it's out
its out forever so I'm saying so what if
her what if she was able to cut that off
at the pass right that's why you have
people like yeah my image was the how I
make money than for sure but it's not
like if I'm behind to see I don't I mean
I even get it on on the scale I'm at
like when I'm posting promotional
pictures for the podcast
I'll always so brick and Nicky first
like hey would y'all approve of your
face in these before I post it I don't
like it make sense right maybe we do
that too but but I'm saying like once
it's out and then you go after them to
be like oh I like shut him up that is
what I would not do because it just
makes you look dumb but definitely
Beyonce's doing here she's heading it
off at the pass she's going yo ap don't
take no pictures of Beyonce we [ __ ] you
up
yeah that also that's what I said it
could also not even be her doing a
computer PR team because I'm the
opposite right like I do photo shoots
for Bartle Brigade stuff all the time
but I'm stupid and all the pictures I
choose make me look dumb but it's my
team that are like can we choose the
better photos to make the brand look
better
hmm so they're actually doing me a favor
and not making a breaking out for the
brand for the brand yeah yeah let me
choose the ugly on the brands on the
brand's worst enemy and then they're
actually not letting me choose them
about the barbel Brigade band that you
guys push so well is that you never look
where you're walking you always look
away from me you never don't actually in
our brand guidelines it should be no
keys we're not even kidding
pinch bible OBS and that's actually born
the brand guidelines joke no I'll show
you after I'll show you both they walk
looking where they're going yeah no I'm
straight full sideways
way is always better than the looking to
Canada yeah it's always better it's the
best there's gonna be Seoul tree and
like sexy right right like I [ __ ]
love this logo how come there's nobody
for doing this [ __ ] love this logo
those are the pictures that I would take
and I'm like I'm choosing that one and
my team is like no he can't be putting
that one I think it has more person now
can we put that one on the fit Expo
booth that we're paying lots of money
for like hey don't be funny
if you're laying down like this that's
what I want on the Billboard you know I
tell people all the time whenever I'm
taking a group picture I'm always like
yo fake laughing pictures are way better
than everybody like awkward so I always
like you caught up in this like fake
candid [ __ ] but everyone looks good
connect their jaws are turned this way
you're smiling and it's not awkward like
edom say yeah yeah yeah that's what my
smiles been for like five years on the
internet go go for the fake laugh I know
Nicky workshop this with me lately and
I've been doing the fake laugh and it's
been working from ha do you wanna [ __ ]
the couch huh
Oh like Oh everyone's [ __ ] the couch
oh oh that's good cause the kappa oh no
got caught gone sexual
[Music]
[Music]